on 911 when you're the operator right
you're the operator the emergency
operator at this point with all your
lines can't you just put the lines in
the screen and not have to memorize them
yeah yeah you don't need to do that
because you're reading them as they're
they get printed out or right well some
yeah some of some of it's up there
because of the things and then some of
it's not because they change they have
to you know they they're constantly like
rewriting or they'll do my part before
they do the emergency or they'll do the
emergency before they do my part so it's
all kind of but yeah I mean it's you
know you're able to you know kind of for
the phone calls and stuff like that it's
actually quite helpful because they will
actually run the phone call up there for
you so that you can you can react as if
you would if you were hearing yeah I
pulled the Brando a few times I would
have like lines written in a book on
Criminal Minds when I was pregnant in
real life like literally my brain was
just gone like I just it's like a thing
when you're pregnant like you just don't
remember anything and so I would write
some of my lines like in the files it
would be on the plane I'd be like oh
suspect is a and he's you know yeah